>>Male #1: Welcome everybody, my name is Thomas
Sharon and I'm a User Experience Researcher
here in Google
New
York and a proud Israeli.
I'd like to briefly share two very quick stories
with you so first story's about Albert
Einstein back in the '40's.
When he was a professor in Princeton, there
came the time to the final exam of the year,
four hundred students in the room.
His assistants pass the tests and then one
of his assistants tells him that-- he
notices that the questions are the same as
last year's questions.
So he comes to Einstein, tells him that, he
looks
at the form and says, "Hmm.
That's okay."
And the assistant says, "How come it's okay?
It's physics and we have--
you know it's the same questions--they'll
know the answers."
He says, "Physics has changed so much in the
past year
the answers are now completely different so
it's okay."
[laughter]
The second story is--two weeks ago I was on
vacation in the West coast with my family,
and at one point we came into
a local supermarket to buy some sandwiches
and a woman was standing behind us in line
and she listened to us speak in
Hebrew and then she approached us and of course
asked a question, "What language are you speaking?"
and I said, the
typical Israeli answer, "Uh, what do you think?"
And she said--she--after a few guesses--wrong
guesses-- she said--
I told her that this was Hebrew.
Her eyes lit.
She said, "I'm from, I'm originally from Morocco
and I'd love--I
want to visit Israel."
And I asked her, "What stops you?" and she
said, "Well, the situation and that it's not
safe."
And then I asked myself really still we need
to answer those questions and I'm asking you
and I’m asking myself
almost every day, " How can we as in the '40's
, as in the '40's physics can change the perception
about Israel and
change the answer, so it is my pleasure to
introduce to you Ambassador Ido Aharoni, Consul
General of the Israeli
Consulate in New York and a twenty year veteran
of Israel’s foreign service whose work on
improving Israel's
positioning in the U.S. is known and appreciated
by many.
Ambassador Aharoni will share his thoughts
and experiences
about country brand management.
And before you start, I really recommend start
going to work with a t-shirt, so
here's one for you.
Welcome.
[applause]
>>Ambassador Aharoni: Thank you so much.
It's a wonderful gift and thank you for doing
this for us.
Before I begin
I'd like to--oh, the t-shirt yes--as you can
imagine, my kids will take it right away--I
won't get a chance to--
thank you.
Thank you so much and before I begin I'd like
to acknowledge the presence of some of my
esteemed
colleagues here, Gil Lainer the person who’s
in charge of public diplomacy--we'll talk
about public diplomacy in a
second-- and I also have here with us today,
Shani Rozanes, who's producing two big events,
one in Washington D.C.
coming up this Sunday titled, "Broadening
the Conversation about Israel" and the second
here in New York City in
mid-June, again titled, "Israel: Broadening
the Conversation."
We'll talk about why we think it's critically
important for Israel to broaden the conversation
about the country.
And lastly but not least, we have here with
us,
[Hela Aroi], who is my own advisor.
She's a Ph.D. candidate whose specialty is
the history of the Zionist Movement
and those of you interested in the history
of the Zionist movement are more than welcome
to ask her questions about
that because this is not what I am going to
talk about today.
I was asked to talk about--less about the
case of
Israel but more about what countries do in
order to improve their overall positioning.
And the first thing I wanted to do was to
ask you, how many of you have heard of the
guy named Erving Goffman?
How
many?
Okay, let me say a few words about Erving
Goffman because I think Erving Goffman's work
is extremely important
in the context of countries and places trying
to change or improve their overall positioning.
Erving Goffman was a
sociologist from Canada who wrote a book--published
a book in the '50's titled The Presentation
of Self in Everyday
Life that really changed the way we understand
social interaction.
What Erving Goffman claimed is that human
beings
will always strive to achieve control over
the other's perception of the social situation.
So if you're in an
interaction with another human being, the
other will always try to control the way you
perceive them, and how do we
achieve this control?
By using symbols, by using things that symbolize
other things, for example--and by the way
that's the reason why his theory was called
Symbolic Interaction Theory--According to
Erving Goffman, all human
beings always try to maintain their back stage,
their behind-the-curtain information inaccessible
to the other while
presenting using symbols, the kind of information
that they'd like to--so for example, the way
we dress; the symbols
that we chose to--for example you gave me
a wonderful example now-- this t-shirt symbolizes
something.
If I go to
work and I walk into my office wearing this
t-shirt, I'm sending a very powerful message
to my employees and to my
staff members, of the kind of manager I am,
the kind of stuff that is important to me
and so on and so forth.
This
is a perfect example of Erving Goffman.
In our day to day life, marketers are using
Erving Goffman's theory on a daily basis.
If you remember the famous
Bush-Kerry Campaign 2004, after Bush won the
elections, his campaign manager gave a speech,
I believe it was in the
following January, January 2005 in which he
said, "We were in a position to tell the way--if
you're driving a BMW
you're more likely to vote for George W. Bush,
if you're driving a Volvo you're more likely
to vote for John Kerry."
And what they actually did, they decoded the
symbols people use and understood the social,
political, and economic
meaning of those symbols and as a result were
able to predict behavior.
And it's all about, I’m sure you all know
that, it's all about the ability of the marketer
to predict the behavior of the consumer.
So Erving Goffman's
contribution, and his book that was published
in the late '50's really changed a lot and
I think gave rise to this
whole notion of let's try to predict the behavior
of the consumer based on the symbols the consumer
chose to use in
the process.
Just a piece of trivia: I am sure you'll recognize
this lady, the late actress Francis Bay, the
marble rye lady from
Seinfeld.
That's Erving Goffman's sister.
[laughter]
The power of brand management: here you're
looking at two products that essentially produce
the same result.
One is a
Mont Blanc that goes for three hundred bucks
I think, two hundred fifty, and the other,
if you're staying at the
Crowne Plaza you can take for free.
And the question that marketers and brand
managers ask themselves is "what makes a human
being spend so much money on
a product when he or she can essentially get
the very same result for nothing?
And the answer of course is the
people who designed the product on the right
created such an attractive persona for this
product that the consumer is
willing to pay that much money only to be
associated with that personality.
That's the power of brand management.
And in country positioning, we say the same
way human beings have personalities, the same
way that human beings have
DNA, the same way products have attractive
personas, also places can be considered to
be attractive or we can decode
and understand their DNA or we can understand
their personalities.
We always use the word personification basically
looking at places the same way you look at
human beings is always
useful in the field of country positioning.
Now you're--Google is a big part of this revolution
but we identified in the field of country
positioning several
changes that occurred as a result of the every
changing technological environment.
The first-- and each of every one
of them is of really critical importance to
every country, every city, every place that
is trying to improve its
over all positioning , that is trying to improve
its performance.
The most important thing that we now know
for
governments to do is to emphasize the need
to engage in a meaningful interaction with
the consumer.
So it's not just
about unilaterally transmitting a message--used
to be in the old days we call it the move
from a system of
broadcasting to a system of narrowcasting,
but it's also the understanding that it's
about quality not about
quantity; that it's about content rather than
about creating an attractive platform and
that people are more mentally
attuned to listen to narrative rather than
cold, clinical, historical, legal arguments.
And governments have got to
look at this revolution and understand that
this is what is required today of them to
do.
Dialogue over monologue;
quality over quantity; content over platform;
and being attractive is more important than
being right.
And the person
who really made a great contribution to this
conversation is an American academic from
Harvard University and is also
an American diplomat whose name is Joseph
Nye who came up--coined the term 'the power
of attraction.'
And places today have to be attractive if
they want to be compete out there.
And the competition between places is
very tough, it's actually vicious and this
the arena we entered shortly after 9/11 here
in New York.
And we decided
to look at Israel the same way you look at
any other brand.
and this is the definition that we adopted:
a brand is a
promise, a strong brand is a promise delivered.
Now in the field of branding, especially--for
many many years there
was a misconception that branding is in the
first place about the ability to create an
attractive visual language.
And we say branding is way more than just
visual language, in fact, branding is--the
real branding has to adopt the
tools used in place positioning.
I always like to tell this story of Israel's
number one bus company called Egged,
that several years ago decided to send a very
strong message to the Israeli consumer, "we
care about the
environment,"
so they hired a branding expert.
He said, "No problem.
You care about the environment, you want to
send this message
to the Israeli consumer, so let's paint the
buses green."
So they did.
They painted the fifty thousand buses in
green.
They forgot to do one little thing and that
is to change the technology.
There's another example in Israel which is
a--the story of my own hometown.
I grew up place called Holon, which is
a, if you may, suburb of Tel Aviv, some one
hundred eighty thousand people and Holon for
many years suffered from a
very bad image.
It was plagued with crime, it was -- had this
boring grey image of an industrial suburb
of Tel Aviv,
south of Tel Aviv.
But about some fifteen-sixteen years ago,
a new mayor was elected.
His name was Moti Sasson.
And
Moti Sasson to do, instinctively, something
very very smart.
He said, "I'm not going to spend money on
advertising
telling people that Holon is a great place.
What I'm going to do is actually turn Holon
into a great place."
He identified that there's a niche in the
Israeli market, there's no places that's catering
especially for children,
and he said "I'm going to turn Holon into
the center for children."
And he invested, for the next five years,
every penny that the city had in infrastructure
that supported his claim to be Israel's "city
of children."
So for
example, he built the children's museum, and
a media center for children.
He came up with this ground breaking
concept of theme playgrounds for toddlers,
in Hebrew called "Gan Sipur".
He bought over twenty of them, and he
built--imagine a toddler is walking to a playground
that is entirely designed based on a classic
children's book,
like "The Giving Tree" or in our case [Chenan
a'chahama] for example it's a great children's
book.
So five years into
the process, Moti Sasson had to spend very
little money on advertising because it became
well known that Holon is
indeed Israel’s city of children because
he was smart enough to create infrastructure,
facts on the ground that
supported the overall strategy that he chose
as a mayor.
Now there are many many aspects to what countries
and places need to do in order to improve
their overall
positioning.
But I would like to mention one of the key
factors is the ability to build partnerships.
It's never
about governments or managements dictating
to the public what needs to be done.
This requires a long, sometimes very
tiring process--never ending process of partnership
building.
And I'll show you in a minute the elements,
the
components of this partnership building process.
Now, country positioning, there are two approaches
to country positioning.
The country positioning that many of you
are exposed to on television and even online
is usually meant to promote tourism.
We call it destination branding.
More and more countries today move to the
other approach, which we call holistic country
positioning model, which
means places, it can be a city or it can be
a country that are interested in improving
their overall
performance across the board.
So it's about attracting tourists; it's about
attracting investors.
It's about
improving the level of exposure of your country's
culture to the world.
It's about the ability to celebrate your
leading export brands so for example if you're
Finland, you have Nokia in the '70s; Sweden
had ABBA, and Volvo; and
countries that actually are identified by
their leading celebrated sub-brands and of
course it's about the people.
The culture and the heritage, I've noticed
that there are several Israelis here in this
room.
So the people, the
Israelis that work and spend time abroad,
they also serve as a channel for Israel to
communicate its identity, its
brand to the world.
So today countries see themselves as brands
too and they are--and they can be managed
the same
way you manage a brand.
Now we started by saying that places have
DNA's, that places have personality.
Let's take the case of Brazil.
What's
the first thing that comes to mind when we
think of Brazil?
I'm asking you?
[several voices, intelligible words]
Soccer, beaches, bikini, Carnival.
If we--when we think of Brazil, we think of
Brazil in the context of only one
thing: fun.
That is the DNA of Brazil.
Now those of you who've been to Brazil know
that indeed there's a lot of fun
in Brazil, but Brazil is not entirely about
fun, right?
If you live in a favela outside of San Paolo--life
is not so
much fun, yet this is the context we all perceive
Brazil.
In place positioning terminology, Brazil is
in a wonderful
position.
Brand Brazil is way up here.
Brazil the product is a little inferior to
the brand, and the gap between the
two is worth billions to Brazil's economy.
As you will see in a few minutes, in Israel's
case, it is exactly the
opposite.
Israel the place, is extremely attractive,
powerful.
Israel's image is so bad that it becomes a
liability and the gap
between the two represents a huge economic
deficit.
Paris.
Paris was branded actually by you, the American
people.
By Hollywood as the world capital of romance.
You
guys are good, either that or you've seen
this presentation before.
[laughter] Paris is about romance and Hollywood
did more to brand Paris than any other branding
agent in the world.
By the way, Hollywood is so powerful that
Hollywood is branding other nations.
We will talk about the most interesting case
study of them all in a few
minutes.
New York.
I want you to know that New York served, and
still serves as our inspiration in Israel
in terms of place
positioning.
What was done here in New York, beginning
in the early '70's, is amazing.
And of course it started in
the early '70's culminated with the great
work that was done during the Giuliani and
Bloomberg administrations.
But
what New York was able to do in less than
thirty years is remarkable.
I want you to think about it.
In the early
'70's, there was a mysterious campaign in
American media.
Someone started to publish ads in American
newspapers
that on a certain day in November of 1972,
New York is going to disappear.
And you know, no one knew who was behind
this bizarre and twisted sense of humor.
And then the next ad, they said that the Statue
of Liberty was going to
go under into the water of the Hudson and
you could see the ad with the sinking Statue
of Liberty.
And the mystery
was resolved when finally the company behind
this bizarre campaign came out.
It was Alitalia.
It was their twisted
way of announcing to the world that they were
launching a direct line that would take you
from Rome to Boston and
from Rome to Washington, D.C. so you don't
have to go through New York.
The mayor of New York at that time, Mayor
Lindsey was alarmed by it.
He said, "Wait a second.
This is the perception of New York?
This is our image?
This is terrible, we have to do
something about it."
In addition to an official complaint that
was sent to Alitalia, a bunch of New York
business people, most notably
the Rudin family, the Tisch family and others
got together with some PR experts and formed
what is still active
until this very day, an organization called
The Association for A Better New York.
What the Association for A Better
New York tried to do is something very simple.
They said "We cannot be defined only by our
deficiencies."
And you
have to remember, in the early '70s, again
Hollywood played a major role here, New York
was defined by its
deficiencies.
New York was branded by Hollywood as the world's
capitol of crime and the world's capitol of
police
corruption.
And they did it through series of movies that
started with Serpico, which is all about police
corruption,
continued with Taxi Driver, Mean Streets,
and movies that celebrated New York as a relentless
producer of crime and
violence.
And as a result people were afraid to come
to New York, add to that the fact that New
York was on the verge
of economic bankruptcy.
Everybody remembers when the City of New York
turned to the federal government asking for
financial aid and President Ford at the time,
1975, said, "I'm not going to give it to you."
The next day New York
Post headline was "Ford to New York: Drop
Dead."
That was really the lowest point in that process
and since then,
since "Ford to New York: Drop Dead"--New York
is slowly and gradually improving its overall
positioning by doing
exactly what needs to be done.
New York identified its own competitive edge
which has two elements, the first is the
size.
Everything in New York is big: the number
of people is huge, the buildings are huge
and also the temptation is
huge to come to New York.
New York is about the totality of your experience
as a consumer.
It is the plus and the
minus, it's the good and the bad.
That is why they wisely chose the apple.
The apple is a religious symbol.
It says
something about temptation.
It comes from the Bible, it's talking to Americans
who care about the Bible.
The Big
Apple communicates very effectively with people
of faith, telling them New York is about the
good and the bad.
It's
about the totality of the New York experience.
And then after the Big Apple came a brilliant
campaign that says "I
love New York" because that's the next level.
After you spark the interest and the curiosity
of the consumer, then
comes the love affair.
And I can tell you at least we're concerned,
Israelis, the New York strategy is working
in a
very big way.
Israelis truly love New York.
When you talk to Israelis about New York,
that's their favorite subject.
Israelis will tell you, "Oh, I love New York.
There's a one restaurant..."
They have their favorite restaurant, of
course, in New York.
They have their favorite stores in New York.
They have everything you need to know about
New
York, you have to ask the Israelis.
They know more about New York than New Yorkers
themselves.
I'm serious.
I'm not
kidding.
And the reason is because New York was successful
establishing real, genuine relationship between
Israel
and the city of New York.
And I can tell you that New York is being
celebrated by Israelis on a daily basis.
You can
find evidence to that in the Israeli media
every day.
The most amazing story is the story of Las
Vegas.
Why?
Because the strategy is so bold, it's so gutsy,
it's so
unbelievable.
What Las Vegas did, they said "Okay let's
look at all of our qualities, advantages and
deficiencies?
And let's choose the biggest problem that
we have."
What's the biggest problem they have?
Las Vegas is about what?
It's about gambling, right?
There's an industry.
There's a consensus in Western civilization,
especially among
people of faith, that gambling is immoral,
it's problematic.
So they said, "Okay, let's take that one deficiency
that
we have--that one problem that is really the
biggest problem that we have--and let's instead
of hiding it, instead of
shying away from it, let's" --do what?--"celebrate
it."
Las Vegas is about sin.
What happens in Vegas, stays in
Vegas.
Hmm.
Interesting.
I'm asking you, what is it that happened in
Vegas that has to stay in Vegas?
[laughter]
What, did we go there to celebrate my son's
Bar Mitzvah?
[laughter]
No.
It was something probably more serious than
that.
I probably lost my house, maybe lost my wife,
who knows what
happened to me in Vegas?
But it's okay, it will stay in Vegas.
Again, Hollywood is branding Vegas as the
ultimate
Sin City.
It's a very bold move on the part of the strategists
of the branding of Las Vegas.
The equivalent would be,
imagining Israel appealing to you, the American
consumer, "Come to Israel for an Explosive
vacation."
[laughter]
Can you imagine that?
That's what Las Vegas did.
[laughter] Pretty amazing.
So we said, "Okay, if Brazil is about fun,
and Paris is about romance, then Israel is
about what?"
Well, we'll talk
about that.
But the guy who is teaching us the most important
lesson is Sacha Baron Cohen.
[laughter]
Sacha Baron Cohen is teaching us country positioning
today is a necessity.
It is not a luxury for countries.
Sacha
Baron Cohen woke up one day, I think it was
maybe eight-nine years ago when he had still
The Ali G Show--this was
before the movie and he said to himself, “I’m
going to take one nation-- a serious nation
with a history of thousands
of years, with rich culture, with lots of
natural resources, with great potential, with
real heritage, with real
political leadership, with real history and
I'm going to singlehandedly redefine their
entire identity and I'm going
to do something to them that they're not expecting.
I'm going to turn them into a joke."
That's what he did,
singlehandedly.
This is before Hollywood.
This is when he had a T.V. show and he created
that character called
Borat.
It's an amazing thing, if you think about
it, an amazing thing.
When the real president of Kazakhstan was
here, I believe in 2005, he held a press conference
at the White House with President Bush.
Sacha Baron Cohen held
his own press conference if you remember.
He had more cameras in his room than the real
one.
Think about it.
Sacha
Baron Cohen is the world's famous Kazakhi.
[Laughter] Yet he never set foot in his life
in Kazakhstan.
And I'm asking
you why was he able to do that?
Why was he able to singlehandedly the identity
of an entire nation?
And the answer
is because, at that point, up until that point
they did very little to define their own identity
to us, the
consumers, in a proactive fashion.
In other words they allowed someone else,
and this is why Sacha Baron Cohen is
teaching us a very very important lesson.
If you will not take the proactive approach
of defining your own identity, be
assured your competition will do it for you.
And that's exactly what Kazakhstan learned
from the experience of Sacha
Baron Cohen.
He taught them that brand capital today is
an integral part of countries’ national
security.
It's not
just about military strength, it's not just
about your ability to execute military operations,
it is also about the
strength of your economy and about your ability
to highlight and communicate your attractive
facets.
We talked about the dramatic change, Google
is part of that dramatic change obviously.
The two things that we need
to do in place positioning, the first thing
is we need to identify our own relative advantages
of place.
So I said
New York identified their size, and the diversity
of the temptation, the city of New York as
their main competitive
edge.
In the case of Paris and Venice, it's all
about romance.
In the case of Brazil, it's all about the
fun and so
on and so forth.
We'll get to Israel's competitive edge in
a second.
But once you've identified your competitive
edge
as a place, the second thing that you need
to do is to find a way to effectively communicate
that relative advantage
To relevant audiences because what you don't
want to do is communicate your competitive
edge to audiences that are
not interested in what you're selling and
not interested in what you have to say.
And I think this is where Google
can be extremely effective and influential.
Here's an example of a work plan that we developed
to celebrate several
niche markets in Israel.
I don't know how many people in the room have
been to Israel and what is the image Israel--
that you have of Israel, but if you will look
at the niche markets on the screen, each and
every one of them can be
celebrated in a big way by the international
community and this is exactly what we're trying
to do as part of the
program that I created called Brand Israel.
This is what countries need and I think that
many of the people in the room have the answers
to the questions that
are posed by nations.
The first thing that we need is someone who
will tell us, and I'm speaking on behalf of
all the nations, and I think
of all the cities in the world interested
in improving their position.
The first thing that we need is to identify
relevant hubs, those relevant Internet intersections
that we need to go through if we want to influence
a
conversation about something.
Let me give you an example.
We have in Israel three marathons-- very distinguished
marathons.
We have the Tel Aviv Marathon, we have the
Tiberias Marathon, and we have the Jerusalem
Marathon, in
addition to the Iron Man and all the triathlons,
but we have three very distinguished marathons.
We'd like to promote
those marathons all over the world.
We know that there are tens of millions of
people around the world that care
passionately about long distance running.
Many of them run the marathons in New York,
in Paris, elsewhere.
We'd like
them to consider Israel as a destination for
long distance running and if they can't afford
to coming to Israel, we'd
like them to be interested, develop curiosity
about the three marathons we have in Israel.
So for example, what we
would do with a company like Google is ask
you can you identify, if I would like to be
part of that conversation
about marathons, can you identify for me the
most important Internet hubs all over the
world that I need to go
through if I were to want to be part of those
conversations.
That's the first step.
A city or country like Israel
would do.
The second thing is once we've identified
those Internet hubs, what we need to do is
find a way that is not self-
congratulatory, that is not Israel approaching
the consumer while saying, "Look at me.
I have such a great marathon."
This is not how it works.
But we need to find a way to engage in a meaningful
conversation with those hubs, that is
being conducted by surrogates, by people that
don't even know that they are my ambassadors.
I have millions of people
out there that are big friends of the state
of Israel and they are passionate about running
long distance marathons
and they're willing to speak on my behalf,
they are willing to celebrate the three marathons
we have in Israel and
they don't even know us.
I'd like to find them, I'd like to know where
they are.
I'd like them to initiate that
conversation.
And then step three of course, it's the one
million dollar question, how do we measure
results?
Can we measure them
effectively?
Can we provide the city or the country with
information that sheds some more light about
the
effectiveness of what we did?
So, here we have a platform.
If we can come up with a solution that is
not just
technological, a solution to all three steps,
we really did something we really did something
major to advance the
conversation about country positioning.
Another way to do it we're talking about online
conversations, but I can tell you again, based
on my own
experience--and I've been doing it for ten
years on and off --targeted exposure events
is the most effective way to
get the word out.
What is a targeted exposure event, you take
a small group of members of the elite, it
can be here
in New York, it can be in Israel.
This event--I consider this event to be a
targeted exposure event.
You bring
people that are clearly part of the creative
class and you share with them your work in
order, again, to engage
ourselves in a meaningful two-way conversation
about the subject matter.
There's nothing more important that that
because then you can actually hear some ideas
from professionals and practitioners and improve
your strategy and your
performance.
The most important thing that places have
to know about country positioning, it's not
about what we say,
it's about what they hear.
You know I always tell this point--there's
a reason for the slide with the penguin--
there's a guy walking down the street who
runs into an old friend.
He sees the old friend, much to his surprise,
has
a penguin marching behind him.
He says to him, "Hey have you noticed there's
a penguin behind you?"
And the friend says, "Of course I know there's
a penguin behind me."
"So, well, what you going to do about the
penguin?
I suggest you take this penguin right away
to the nearest zoo.
"
The friend says, "That's a great idea."
The next day he sees the same friend again,
marching with the same penguin.
He says, "Hey didn't I tell you to take
him to the zoo?"
"Yeah, yesterday we went to the zoo.
Today we're going to the movies."
[laughter]
It's not about what we hear, it's about what
they say.
And in order for us to know what they say,
we need to conduct
research and we'll talk about that in a second.
Countries and organizations sometimes are
convinced that the task at hand is to win
a debate.
It's not about winning
As I said before it's about engaging in a
real meaningful conversation.
Research is a key for places, they
have a tendency to rely heavily on quantitative
research.
I think that the biggest mistake that places
do is that
they're not investing enough in qualitative
research.
They're not investing enough in actually talking
to people, .
interviewing them, trying to understand what's
going on when it comes to the quality of the
emotional tie that is
created between a place and a consumer.
We talked about the need to form partnerships.
This is the model that was developed by Placebrands.
Oh, I'm sorry.
This is the model that shows you--these are
the elements that have to form the partnership.
So obviously you have to
have the government represented; you have
to have the business sector; you have to have
the third sector-- we
described the non-profit sector; the masses--the
people--the public; you have to have the cultural
establishment; and
of course in our case, in the case of Israel,
you have to have world Jewry that we call
the Diaspora.
This is really
the model for Israel's partnership in order
to change the way Israel is communicating
itself to the world.
This is
the personality that we came up with and these
are the relative advantages that Israel possesses
that we would like
to communicate using narrow marketing--narrowcasting
and micro-marketing systems.
We talked about "what is Israel's relative
advantage?"
We, again through massive research, we came
to the conclusion
that Israel's unique advantage is the amazing
creative spirit that exists in Israel.
That is manifested in almost
every realm of life, it's manifested in all
six areas here from Lifestyle and Leisure
to the Environment to Hi-tech
and Science to the Diversity of the people
of Israel to the Culture, the Art, and of
course Israel's unbelievable
comprehensive and vast International aid program
that most Israeli's never heard of, let alone
Americans.
This is
something that we need to change and every
pillar, every lens you see here Israel possesses
a clear relative
advantage and our job is to make sure that
you--the American people-- are aware of that.
And that's we are titling
this effort "Broadening the conversation"
but Israel, because the current conversation
is all about Israel's problems
with its neighbors and we believe that there's
very little benefit for us in the sense of
promoting tourism,
promoting investment, promoting culture, continuing
with this celebration.
When you ask Israelis--and I will end with
that--when you ask Israelis, "What is your
own self impression?
What is
your own self-perception?"
This is what you're getting usually.
And these are actually---these are results
from a
qualitative study conducted in Israel in 2007-2008.
So you can see Israelis see themselves first
of all as Western,
modern, creative.
They see themselves as a world hi-tech leader.
They are--you know, they mention the Palestine--the
Israeli-Palestinian conflict--they mention
anti-Semitism and other problems that they
are aware of, but by--by and
large Israelis think they're very cool.
[laughter] Bottom line, Israelis think they're
very cool.
But what is it that
the world sees?
What is it that Israel as a collective communicates
to the world?
This is what the world sees, this is what
you see on the news.
You see Israel with the military might and
you see the
Palestinians depicted by the media clearly
as the underdog.
And we believe it is possible for us to create
attraction using this conversation.
And our research shows that no matter where
you're coming from, no matter
whether you support the tank or you support
the boy, the entire context is not attractive
to most people.
In
America, in Asia, in Europe.
So what is it that we can do because this
conversation is very powerful.
I'm not interested in trying to hide it by
the way.
I'm not interested in trying to minimize it.
I certainly would like you to believe that
the tank is right
and that the tank is actually being victimized
by our neighbors and so on.
But I realize that most of you are not interested
in that conversation.
So our job, in the case of Israel's country
positioning, is to make sure that we open
other
channels of communications through which Israel
can be communicated to you that are relevant
to you.
And those
channels of communication, without hiding
the conflict, those channels are extremely
attractive.
And Israel is
possessing a clear relative advantage in each
and every one of them.
So it can be music and the arts, it can be
fashion, it can be energy and the environment,
it can be lifestyle, wine and food, and it
can be international aid
programs and great sightseeing, and great
advancements in the field of technology and
hi-tech--you see here the
Pill cam and so on and architecture and the
conflict too.
The conflict is even at the very center of
this mosaic of
pictures but the conflict cannot be the only
thing defining Israel to the world.
Because Israel is way more than it's
troubles.
Israel is way more that it's issues with its
neighbors.
And I always give the example of the context
of two people arguing constantly no matter
who's right and who's wrong,
at one point the consumer is tired of the
discussion.
The consumer becomes fatigued by the debate,
and both sides
stand to lose from it, so we say our job is
to take back the conflict and put it in the
right proportion.
There's a
whole world out there that we can approach,
that we can be appealing to and we're not
because we're stuck on the
question of who's right and who's wrong, and
this is what we would like to change.
Let me just end with an amusing story and
open the floor for your questions.
They tell the story about Golda Meir,
our Prime Minister in the years between 1969
and 1974, then in 1972 was asked to host the
German Chancellor at the
time, his name was Willy Brandt, in Tel Aviv.
And someone wisely advised Golda,"If you want
to impress Willy Brandt,
take him on a tour of German architecture
in Tel Aviv.
He will like it."--we have thousands of Bauhaus
buildings in
Tel Aviv-- so she did and they concluded the
tour at the HaBima Square--those of you who've
been to Tel Aviv know
it's our national theater--and she told him,
"This is our National Theater.
Right next to it," she said, " is the
Mann Auditorium, our Performing Arts Center."
And Willy Brandt said, "Oh my God, I can't
believe you the Israelis made the decision
to name your own performing
arts center after the famous German author
Thomas Mann!"
And Golda looked at him and said, "No, no,
no.
We named it after Freddie Mann from Philadelphia."
He said, "Freddie Mann from Philadelphia,
what did he write?"
She said, "He wrote a check."
[laughter]
There's a tough competition out there, between
cities and countries, if Israel, or any other
country, will not be
able to communicate effectively its attractive
dimensions to the world, it will impair its
own ability to be
competitive.
It becomes an impediment.
And the realization that we realized shortly
after 9/11, that we have a lot
to offer you, the American people.
And I think that the success of the book,
Start Up Nation, proves that point.
There's a book, it's not about the conflict,
that became a best seller.
And the reason why the book became a best
seller--and if you haven't read the book,
I urge all of you to read that book-- the
reason why Start Up Nation became
such a best seller is because it's relevant.
It's relevant to the American people struggling
with economic crises.
Here's a story of a tiny nation, surrounded
by enemies, that did it the other way.
Let's try to learn from them.
Israel can be a source of inspiration for
many Americans, and our job is to make sure
that you are aware of it.
Your questions please.
[Applause]
One at a time please.
Yeah?
>>Male #2: Hey there.
One question is have you heard of the U.S.
Brand U.S.A. program, are you familiar with
it at all?
>>Ambassador Aharoni: I was just--it was just
brought to my attention and I know that some
of them are online right
now listening to this presentation so I would
love to meet with them and have a conversation
with them with pleasure.
>>Male #2: Okay, if you want to talk afterwards.
We're people who work that team here--
>>Ambassador Aharoni: Oh wonderful!
>>Male #2: They'd love to hear something like
this.
>>Ambassador Aharoni: By the way, I think
that Brand U.S.A., not your program, but U.S.A.
as a brand is the strongest
brand in the world.
And we can have a whole conversation about
why the United States is such a strong brand,
but I
can tell you in country positioning you have
the United States, and then the rest of the
world.
>>Male speaker#2: Sort of on that note, so
you mention using the Israeli Diaspora to
recruit people for various--
>>Ambassador Aharoni: Jewish Diaspora also.
>>Male #2: Jewish Diaspora--okay.
So I feel like the Jewish Diaspora, at least
in America, is a little more
strongly affiliated with Israel because of
the stigma of leaving for example.
The American Diaspora, I think, has
less of that element I feel like there are
Americans who live abroad who sort of want
nothing to do with America,
and I'm kind of curious what your views are
about recruiting that diaspora to actually
enlist their support.
>>Ambassador Aharoni: Two advices.
The first is, leave politics out of the game,
out of the conversation.
And the
second thing is, try to identify what is it
that makes America such a great brand.
Think about it.
We said, "Brand
is a promise.
A strong brand is a promise delivered."
What is the DNA of the United States?
America is about what?
What's the one word that defines--
>>Unknown speaker: Freedom.
>>Ambassador Aharoni: Freedom, exactly.
The United States is about freedom and the
fact that freedom is being
supported in almost every of dimension of
life in America, whether you look at the political
system, even the
physic-- the, you know, physical experience
of traveling in America is about freedom.
The outdoors, the highways.
You go to California, you go to Texas, you
take the--you know-- you go on the road on
a road trip, you see all--you
can smell the freedom in America.
It's so powerful, it's so sensual.
And so this is your main asset.
To what extent,
does an American who made a decision to live
in Paris for political, ideological reasons,
or for business reasons
cares about the fact that America celebrates
freedom?
That's the question that you have to ask.
To what extent these
people, that American diaspora overseas, deeply
cares about the DNA of the United States?
And I think once you'll be
able to answer that question, it will be easier
to come up with a program that is relevant
to them.
My feeling, and again, my gut feeling--I'm
married to an American who moved to Israel--in
fact, I'm the only non-
American in my family.
I'm the only person in my immediate family
that doesn't have an American passport.
And I can
tell you that in the case of Americans who
move out of America, you know, something else
motivates them.
It's not the
celebration of American freedom.
Something else, they found purpose elsewhere,
and you need to understand what's that
thing that they discovered.
>>Male speaker#2: Thank you.
>>Male #3: Hi, you talked a little bit about
how Hollywood had promoted the image that
New York City was a
dangerous place full of crime up through the
'70s.
Hollywood is still making those films it seems,
so what actually
changed?
It seems almost like the films we watch are
a romantic version of that but it doesn't
seem like that's
actually what changed and got people to see
New York differently.
>>Ambassador Aharoni: Well, many--you know
in the case of New York, what changed is an
effort that was made mostly by
the private sector at first, and then was
embraced by official agencies in the city
of New York to highlight the
other facets of New York, yeah, without ignoring,
yes, there's still pockets of violence and
there's still dangerous
places in New York, and obviously the ultimate
thing that happened was in the end, when the
city cleaned the streets
and doubled the number of police officers.
That was a huge decision that really was of
strategic importance.
It's
never just about Hollywood, but Hollywood
is a big part of it.
And again, if you will not take the proactive
approach, Hollywood will redefine you.
And that's exactly what happened in the '70's,
New York didn't do enough
creating attractions, and you know it's a--if
you're really interested in the case of New
York, I urge all of you to
read the book, Branding of New York, it was
published in 2008 by a sociologist from Columbia
University whose name is
Miriam Greenberg.
It's a fascinating book, it's a history book
actually about the process.
It talks about how they
made a decision, for example, those families
to invest in NYU in the '70s.
To turn NYU--to create NYU as a
counterbalance to the economic and academic
strength of Columbia.
So there was a need to create another academic
magnet in Manhattan, and they made a decision
it's going to be NYU.
And it was such an elaborate program, brilliant
program, I urge all of you to read that book.
Read that book.
>>Male #3: Would you say that New York is
a promise delivered in this case?
>>Ambassador Aharoni: Absolutely!
Absolutely!
New York, to my mind, is the most amazing
case study in place
positioning.
Amazing, in thirty years, they totally overhauled
the positioning of New York.
I think that second would
probably be the case of Spain, post-Franco.
And a remarkable effort on the part of the
Spanish government.
>>Male #3: Thanks.
>>Male #4: I'd say in most cases where a city
or a country is trying to brand itself it
doesn't face an
organized opposition where the opposition
is resisting that branding, you know, so if
France wants to be the city of
romance, no one's going to say "NO. no, France--
not romantic."
But in the case of Israel, obviously there
is an
organized opposition, you know, you can imagine
in the old days, if South Africa had tried
to brand itself as the
place to come for business and safaris, there
would have been significant push back, saying,
"You know what South
Africa is."
So how do you deal with the fact that you
can't just brand yourself and send the message
out unopposed?
>>Ambassador Aharoni: Right.
First, that's an excellence question.
It means only one thing for us.
We have to work
harder.
We have to work harder.
It's true that no one will tell France, "No,
you're not romance."
But don't forget
that Paris is facing some tough competition
in Europe itself.
In the case of romance, the competition comes
from
Venice.
But it's true, it's not a negative branding.
But the good news is that people really don't
care.
Here--I put
a slide here of a study that we conducted
as Israel was going into Gaza, so you can't
say this study was not
conducted when Israel was not in the news.
Israel was in the news, and in a very negative
context.
Okay, Israel was
going into Gaza in early 2009.
We went to fourteen countries to look at their
perception of Israel's personality.
This was not about Israeli policies, it was
about Israel's personality, but we did start
the study with the baseline
question, "On the conflict between Israelis
and Palestinians, where do you stand?"
In blue or purple, whatever the
color is, is the level of support for Israel.
In pink or red, is the level of support for
Palestinians.
I want you to
pay attention to the results in France.
This is France.
You see, in France, and by the way, we asked
only the elite
in those societies.
The elite--the people who earn above average
and at least have one college degree, okay?
So you
look at the case of France, sixteen percent
of the French elite to your point sir, support
the Palestinians.
Only
nine percent of the French elite support the
Israelis, right?
So traditionally what we try to do was to
change the
inner balance between the two groups and move
people from the group of sixteen to the group
of nine.
And we tried to
do that using historical and legal arguments.
Like, you know, "we are right and they are
wrong" and all that.
Marketing experts looked at this and said,
"Wait a second, put sixteen and nine together,
what do you get?
Twenty-
five percent.
Seventy-five percent of the French elite couldn't
care less about the conflict what is it that
you
bring to them?"
And we checked ourselves, and we looked at
what we actually brought to them over the
years, and we
discovered that what we brought to them was
exactly the same argumentation that produced
the nine percent.
In other
words, we were turning them off.
On a daily basis.
And when we changed the message, when we changed
the content of
the communication, when we started communicating
to them things that they care about, for example,
lifestyle and
leisure.
Israel is a great culinary experience.
Israel is a great--we have great wine, we
have an emerging olive oil
industry.
The best olive oil in the whole world comes
from Israel.
We have great fashion designers in Israel.
Great
filmmakers in Israel.
So it's true, when you have to deal with a
political crises like the flotilla, you don't
talk
about fashion.
It's not a crises management tool.
But when you need to build an overarching
persona, overarching
strategy you have to talk about those things
because that's exactly the kind of human experience
that creates the
emotional tie.
And I can tell you, for example the gay community
in Europe, Israel's been extremely successful
in
engaging them in a conversation that is meaningful.
Why?
Because in the case of the gay community,
Israel delivers on
the promise in a big way.
There is no country in our hemisphere, in
our region, that is more gay friendly than
Israel, and that's a fact.
And this fact is being celebrated by gay people
all over the world.
No more questions, I'm sorry, the big brother
said no more questions.
>>Unknown speaker: No more time.
>>Ambassador Aharoni: No more time.
Thank you so much, I'll be accessible here
if you have questions.
[applause]